all right madame vice president
everything's falling apart the
president's approval rating is terrible
yours is somehow even worse all of your
legislative priorities dead your
administrative priorities dead because
of the supreme court
the american people rejecting what you
want
across the entire board
how are you going to change course
at what point does the administration
say you know what this strategy isn't
working we're going to change studies
six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to do what we have
been doing and that time is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
franklin roosevelt famously said
we have nothing to fear but fear itself
ronald reagan famously said
mr gorbachev
tear down this wall
and kamala harris famously said
it's the time now to do what we've been
doing every day in the time and the time
to agree that we are doing
that we've got things to do together and
the time
powerful it's really power doesn't it
sends a shiver up your spine shiver up
your spine to think that this woman
could become the vice president of the
united states she is obviously a good
politician
she is by definition she's a good
politician she's the vice president
i called this by the way you know i hate
to say i told you so i called this
during the 2020 democrat primaries i
said watch kamala harris people laughed
at me they said ha ha camalera she's
terrible i said watch kamala harris
then she's one of the first people out
they laugh at me they say ha ha michael
you idiot the kamalaris isn't going
anywhere
kamala harris is a heartbeat away from
the presidency and the current president
doesn't have a very strong heart
so she's clearly a good politician she's
worked her way up she's not particularly
academically distinguished she's not
particularly professionally
distinguished but she worked her way up
in politics
through various mechanisms that we don't
need to get into here
she became a united states senator and
she became the vice president at a
relatively young age that's impressive
but she's a terrible
communicator she is
she is less coherent than joe biden
and joe biden
has problems in between his ears right
now okay and somehow she's worse
this is the only thing politically joe
biden has going for him is that his vice
president is somehow less popular than
he is
even though he's extremely unpopular his
vice president is somehow less coherent
than he is even though he's obviously in
the throes of senility
that is something because if potentially
i could stave off an impeachment
if joe biden even lasts if he even makes
it that far it's really important to
diversify your investments all the time
but especially when the economy is a
little kooky right now inflation is at
40 year highs
4-0
it's here to stay
do you know why it's here to stay
because the government's dirty little
secret is they want it
think about this right now inflation
rates are higher than the interest on
treasury bonds so with every day that
passes the government owes less on its
mountain of debt
imagine for instance if your mortgage
had a negative interest rate would you
be in a hurry to pay it off would you
make extra payments every month
and no i don't think so so your pain is
the government's gain protect your
savings now hedge against inflation with
gold from birch gold because the
government is sabotaging the value of
the us dollar birch gold will help you
convert an eligible ira or 401k into an
ira backed by real gold that is peace of
mind that's why i am a huge huge fan of
birch gold with thousands of satisfied
customers and an a plus rating with the
better business bureau you can trust
birch gold to protect your savings text
knowles kennedwles to 989898
to get a free info kit on holding gold
in a tax sheltered account then call
birch and protect your hard earned
savings text null scanner wlas to 98
98.98 to get your free info kit now
really bad news
for the democratic ticket in 2024 so bad
that kamala harris
refuses to say that that she and joe
will even be running during the next
presidential cycle
are we going to uh to see the same
democratic ticket in 2024
i'm sorry we are thinking about today i
mean honestly that i i know why you're
asking the question because
this is the part of the punditry and the
the gossip around places like washington
d.c let me just tell you something we're
focused on the things in front of us
uh
uh we're just uh uh lady this is not a
hard question this is not an unexpected
question
how do you not have an answer for this
question this is basic stuff
for a vice president especially in a
troubled administration
we're we're
just thinking about today no we're
obviously not just thinking about today
that's why the interviewer asked the
question are you going to be on the
ticket
but she can't say
that she or or biden are going to be on
the ticket
why
because the administration is underwater
and because they haven't accomplished
anything this is the best news for
conservatives is they really
have not accomplished much of anything
their entire legislative agenda has been
destroyed
they can't even pass a budget they can't
even pass a budget the buildback better
program is dead and it was killed
obviously the republicans were opposed
to it but then it was killed decisively
by a couple of democrats
the filibuster killed by
republicans and a couple of democrats
the filibuster
abolition plan
the court packing
the federal election takeover the whole
thing so they were not able even though
joe biden had served in the senate for i
think 350 years he wasn't able to use
those relationships to
bring his legislative agenda over on
capitol hill so then he tried to figure
out a workaround his work around was
going to be to use the administrative
state the agencies to force through his
vaccine mandate
that didn't work either because the
court shot it down
so why would
biden and harris run again
what have they done what could they run
on what accomplishment what promise of
an accomplishment could they run on
got to ring that bell
that's that's how you're going to get
the notifications when the new videos
come out
probably the best way actually is you go
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show
subscribe
leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you